die
bitte mit einer auf sechs folge so leute
wir sitzen sie gerade am dreh von der
letzten folge von action haus und für
mich ist jetzt diese woche zu ende
zwar richtig echt mega viel spaß gemacht
und ich würde sagen wir gehen das ganze
einfach mal so zusammen durch in der
letzten folge crash bei mega cool weil
allein weil ich lukas herum bauen konnte
ich bin der festen überzeugung dass die
märkte ungarn ab als er mich mega lustig
also mit peter und ein hat mega fun
gemacht
trampolinspringen mit nerd ganz richtig
cool
jona was auch entschuldigt weil ein
bisschen was beigebracht auch wenn ich
zugegebenermaßen so ein bisschen das
opfer war beim trampolinspringen achten
wir auch fang gemacht so natürlich
fallschirm springt mit der lieben diana
die fashion spielen kann man nicht so
wirklich vergleichen mit was weil du
fällst aus dem flugzeug heraus und du
fällst einfach sie ist erst mal nur die
wolken so unter dem text im
kirchenschiff was passiert jetzt
also es war definitiv mit eines meiner
highlights wenn ich sogar das kurze
überhaupt würde ich sofort wieder machen
dann kartfahren war natürlich auch die
competition mit meinem bruder
nicht optimal aus leider aber auch mega
viel spaß gemacht und zu mal sowas
motorsport mäßiges drin zu haben
also das war auch sehr natürlich aus
spanien wo wir gerade sind
ich war aber auch mega kraft also allein
ist einfach so was ganz anderes gewesen
so ok höhe einmal beim
fallschirmspringen ist wieder dasselbe
vielleicht so überhaupt
aber es war ganz anders weil die nutzer
selbst entscheiden schnell läuft ist
traurig nicht und du bist du du hast ja
sozusagen gesprungen weil falsche sprit
und hier weiß auf jeden fall auch meine
kasse etwa so aus 50 metern
heruntergelaufen also insgesamt kann man
sagen nur dass die straße woche hat mir
viel spaß gemacht ich hoffe euch auch
und
eine kamera ist schwer auszumachen